ladies and gentlemen Brian Boitano and
Alan sack Ian oh boy so that was what is
that like 10 feet in diameter yeah it
was scary and it was elevated so if you
fell off you would basically die in
front of everybody
you know that's watching the Super Bowl
halftime show but it was it was plastic
actually so it was plastic ice and they
put this vegetable oil on it to make
your blades slide but your blades get
really warm and your feet start burning
because of the friction and the only
time I'd ever skated on it was the night
before they had us on the field on those
stages and I practiced probably two
hours because I couldn't do anything and
it was it was really hard it's it's hard
to skate on plastic as you guys can
imagine when you're used to ice but not
as hard as winning that's that's true
hard in a different way
yeah so you wanted to talk about this
overcoming fear and anxiety associated
with our this doubt that we get when we
chase our dreams and our goals yeah yeah
you know I mean I think everybody
struggles with that I I learned at a
very young age that the mental side of
competition was gonna be the hardest
thing to you know get under my belt and
and be secure with it wasn't the actual
performance or the athleticism or
anything like that it was what was gonna
happen when I was under this immense
pressure of representing my country and
my family and knowing that the you know
going into the Olympic Games it could
change your life depending on how you
did so at a very young age I started
practicing my mental strength you know
let lessons for mental strength and I
got to this you know one point where
everybody has that sort of voice inside
of their
and that's that always judges you it's
the judgmental voice and I named it
Murphy for Murphy's Law and it would
always tell me that I couldn't do things
and you know when I was in a practice it
would be like you're not gonna be able
to do that and then you know III
actually put together like this tool
chest of things that would counteract
Murphy and I practiced it on a regular
basis so the most valuable thing in the
tool chest was the fact that you can
talk back to the negative voice and if
you speak speak for me when I would
speak in harsher tones it would subside
it would go away
you can't just be kind with it I
wouldn't be like hey Murphy don't need
you around right now it's like I just
really need to you know do this great
performance it's like Murphy get out of
here like literally it's being forceful
with them and those were some of the
things that you know that that I learned
along the way that really helped in fact
as I was skating out when they announced
my name after the warm-up my six-minute
warm up and they said representing the
United States and I was skating out and
I was actually making laps in front of
my coach before I went out and Murphy
came in and said and like started
talking those you're gonna blow it
you're gonna blow it and I said I
started talking back to I'm like no no
I'm I'm consistent I practiced I'm ready
for this I know I can do it nope you're
gonna blow it and this is gonna be the
first time that you blow it and it's
gonna be in front of all these people in
the Olympics and you know everybody's
watching and I literally had this
conversation inside of my head with
Murphy about to make it go away
and by the time I had reached my
position where the music was starting I
had gotten rid of Murphy and I literally
turned my whole night around and would
you say that that then takes you into a
state of flow once you're not worrying
about anxiety the thing about anxiety
and the thing about judgmental voices is
that it can snowball and get so out of
control and so quickly and when you're
an athlete
the thing is that one negative thought
like I always say this it things kick
when you're in in competition and things
are happening very fast there can be a
thought like a simple thought like oh I
had Tomatoes today and that was my good
luck food a year ago at the World
Championships and that makes you feel
strong but there are also little
negative things that you can think of
too and once those negative things get
planted in your brain it snowballs so
quickly one thing becomes the next thing
and then you miss an element in the
program and then you then you're judging
yourself more and then the negative you
just can't stop it so my in my toolbox
my secret was to never let that voice
get any traction at all and so that's
why I discovered Murphy because as soon
as I had a negative thought I was like
get rid of it now I'm not gonna let it
start a small small snowball that can
that can grow into a large snowball
I like the harsh voice the your taking
control of it
yeah you're forcing it you're like this
is the this is my body this is my life
you're you're you act you don't the
negative thought it's a judgemental
voice is what it is it's judging you and
you know and and and you don't you can
change your mind you can change your
thoughts and it it makes sense that you
would be strong with it would you say
that you also run simulations in your
head of what it would look like to fail
or do average or succeed with flying
colors and then you see how those things
all play out it's interesting that's a
really good question I've never had
actually anyone asked that I used to do
this visual imagery every night before I
would go to bed and I would imagine
myself skating a clean program and being
at the end and the standing ovation and
like feeling great about myself and
imagining that I was doing a clean
performance you know sometimes that
stuff wasn't natural to my visualization
I would make mistakes in my
visualization and so then then what I
would do it was I switch up I would
imagine a
performance that was just terrible I'd
be like I'm falling on everything I'm
just imagining it and I'm imagining it
I'm clearing the plate and then I would
go back to imagining perfection and if I
couldn't see the perfect jumping I would
just imagine the feeling that I had at
the end of the performance that's all I
would visualize I would imagine myself
like with my fists going like this
sensing that I like had done a great
performance and then maybe visualize me
on the top of the podium with the
American flag behind me yes yeah no I'm
sure that we all have judgment and
anxiety that comes up about our goals
but how many of us actually practice the
simulations of succeeding raise our hand
it's pretty good yeah let's think it
maybe a third that seems to be a crucial
component of the process yeah is he
visualizing succeeding in the end
position and all the short-term steps
you need to take along the way to get
there and it's a commitment you can't be
lazy about it it's important but if you
don't think it's important you're not
gonna do it people need to realize that
it's it's it's a total element and it's
a total layer of the importance of what
you want to achieve and but but if you
just do it every once in a while or that
you have to be committed it's like you
know eating breakfast every morning or
having caught you know it's like I do
that and then this is my time that I'm
gonna work on this you work on different
things you work on your body work on
your mind you work on yes staying
positive yes
and so by repeating these certain
procedures that help you reach your
goals for example the triple axel you
know first person in the u.s. to land on
that is incredible feat to accomplish
and so with us we don't just get to that
end goal how did how did you program
yourself to focus and repetition and to
get used to your spirit of wanting to go
do that over and over again until you
were able to achieve it I think it's
passion I mean you got to be passionate
for what you're doing I mean I I I
wanted to do anything and everything
that I could to make myself better
because it was so I was so passionate
about skating I wanted that's what I
mean when I just
covered skating at a very young age I
knew I wanted it to be for the rest of
my life I loved it so much so because
that passion was there you are able to
say okay now okay so now the passion is
there I want to do the work I really
want to do the work and it doesn't
matter what kind of work it is if I want
to be successful at this I want to do
anything anything that I can do that
will help me and that's where passion
comes in because you have to commit to
doing those little things you might not
want to do but you're like it's good for
me I've got to do it it's kind of like
putting all your chips in yeah it is it
is like putting yeah putting everything
on everything in and you know a lot of
the times when you put all your chips in
there are some elements that you don't
really like doing but you know what it
is for you and you got to do it yeah for
example I could have had six cookies
today
Murphy's like you could add that same
cookie like I'm going back to the salad
yeah that's that's such a crucial
component all these chips forward some
of us even though there's certain
aspects of putting ourselves fully in we
all do some sort of work with our
entrepreneurship that might not seem to
be the highest level visionary work it
seems to be tedious and we're like oh I
can't wait until somebody else does this
part so I could focus on the high level
stuff but we get through that we we go
through that with flying colors and
achieve that and then it opens up the
door for us to do that high level vision
later on and other people will help us
help with the same vision so maybe with
this whole like all chips forward it
seems as though again that's just such a
necessity to wake up in the morning and
have I call it a fire under your ass
yeah yeah so to have that burning super
bright and waking up in the morning and
knowing that this is what I'm building
into the world yeah yeah you had that
and yeah and I think that you that leads
to different things that leads to you
have to have a plan everybody has to
like know the stepping stones I always
when I
you skate program in San Francisco where
I have school kids come in and learn
skating and invariably with these young
kids they they come in and they they say
I want to learn how to spin this is
their first time on the ice I'm like
well I can't really spin yet but I'm
gonna you know I'm gonna tell you that
the very first thing that you should
start learning to do is swizzles with
their feet they're like no I want to
learn how to spin and I'm like well
these are stepping stones and you got to
take the first stepping stone to get to
spinning and maybe in a couple lessons
you'll learn how to spin
they don't want nothing to do with that
and they they don't really understand
and this is one of the most valuable
things that I learned as an athlete is
you can't go from A to Z without going
from A to B and to see entity you know
it's like it little you have to go you
have to figure it out and that's part of
the plan how do you go what's what's on
level B I'm at a so-so to get there and
my coach used to make note notebooks for
me even at age eight and say bye you
know March next year you should be doing
a double toe loop consistently so it's
like I had these these notes and these
these things of like how to how to take
it to the next level and every time you
make the next level it's this shell of
strength that gets over you like people
always say to me how did you deal with
that pressure of the Olympics and like
literally it's you know and when I look
back at it now I think how did I deal
with that pressure of the Olympics but
it's those shells that cover you and you
go to those little layers and you just
get used to it as you go and it's like
you're you live your life and just one
little thin shell keeps covering you
covering you and then all of a sudden
it's this enormous shield over you and
it's protecting you from this incredible
incredible energy that's that's pressure
that is pressure and we all have been in
our life and
you know it may not be able the level of
an Olympics but to every every each
person it is their Olympics you know
what I mean yeah so you've got to use
that same format for life as you do in
sports or the Olympics I love that
analogy you're going from A to Z but you
got to get to BCD even after there's no
skipping and you're building the shield
yeah as well yeah down the line
pressure's easy yeah comes easy
yeah after a while and the people who do
get lucky and go from A to Z like very
quickly they always have to go back to B
they do as you I knew skaters who were
much more talented than me and they just
did like you know they would try their
this their triple loop and they've
landed the first time and they'd land it
you know the next week in the next week
but when it came down to competition and
then being nervous and they're like oh I
don't even know what I think of on this
it's not I don't know my technique I I
just do it and then they would miss it
in competition and so then they'd have
to go back to B to figure out exactly
the technique that they were thinking of
I was the opposite way I didn't land
anything quickly ever but on those on
those layers and those layers I learned
exactly what worked and didn't work and
I remembered those so by the time I
would get into competition I'm like okay
I know to do a triple loop I can't I
have to have my left arm here instead of
here and that's what works whereas those
people so those people had to go back to
B whereas I would do it in order yeah
did you apply any practices of
meditation or yeah breath work
everything and that's it was important
to do it on a daily basis so I did
breath work I did relaxation techniques
I would do it I skated for five five and
a half hours a day and I would do it
constantly practicing and I would
imagine that each time I did a
run-through well I would only allow
myself one run-through of the program
and I would imagine that this was a
competition so it was my one and only
time I would get nervous every day for
my practices and during those practices
I would I would do like my techniques
you know relaxing my shoulders you know
you hear about the simple techniques
this
techniques are the most efficient - it's
like imagine yourself going down in an
elevator it's like 10987 you know you
that whole thing relaxing your shoulders
relaxing your arms but then there were
other nuances that I discovered like
that the relaxing my arms I rely I read
a book about how just if your arms are
relaxed and so I would use that during
my skating program so when I would be
getting nervous or my biggest jump was
coming up I'd be like relax your arms
and I would use it as part of the
choreography of the the thinking process
it's like my technical thing like how I
talked about to do my triple loop I knew
my arm had to be here
I would actually choreograph the thought
of relaxing my arms into the program so
that was part of my toolbox that
elements in my toolbox that I discovered
it seems like maybe relax is a crucial
part of flow of getting into flow huge
that's very insightful the the most you
know the more relaxed the more relaxed
that you can be the more you can allow
your your body to just do what what
comes naturally to it I always say if
people force themselves too much they
usually their movement like for at least
an athlete their movement it and I don't
know this might be with your brain too
if if you do what comes naturally to you
or what's organic I think it's probably
the right thing to do so if you can just
get to a point where you do relax in
that way you usually organically go to
the right choice yeah
so right I don't know if it's right or
wrong but it would work for me
you know but simultaneously vigilant as
well yes yes absolutely yes which is
that that's tough to find that but
relaxation and being vigilant at the
same time it's I mean it's it's it's a
dance but it's it's about practicing it
it doesn't come overnight it's something
that you have to learn how to do yeah
and everybody has a different different
level of vigilance and versus versus
relaxation you know what I mean yeah so
right now you're what are your focuses
you skates a big focus right now you
skate you know it's one of my focuses
what did I do
I do yeah I do a lot of can't stop
thinking about the kids that came in in
their life yeah I want to spin they do
they're like dreamers but the good thing
about the kids coming in for you skate
is they can't skate with phones in their
hands it's like it's like literally they
put the phones down and they're actually
skating it's so nice to see you know
them being able to do something that
they feel good about themselves this
accomplishment and we try to encourage
them you know as much like you know if
they're holding on to the rail and five
minutes they're not you're like oh
you're off the rails so it's like it's
nice for kids to have this athletic
element that they can feel good about
themselves you know and it's not about
you know oh they're gonna be a champion
someday it's just about feeling good
about yourself yeah you know and their
training their motor skills as well yeah
so let's talk about your focus is now
what are you focused on what are you
building into the world now I'm actually
really focused I did a show on Food
Network and a show on HGTV and so I'm
actually in South Park I did that for I
got to tell you talking about the youth
some of the youth scares me just because
one one of the kids some of the kids
came into the rink and they said you're
the dude on South Park what was it like
to be on South Park and I'm like well no
first of all they said we didn't know
you skate I'm like well I'm
on South Park so it's like I'm like I
I'm skating in the animated thing and
they're like yeah what was it like to be
on South Park and I'm like well I wasn't
really on South Park it's animated and
they're like yeah but you were still on
it right and I'm like yeah but it was in
it they didn't get it so I was like okay
I'm moving on to the next murphy's like
let these kids go oh yeah so anyway I'm
doing I'm trying to do stuff that's a
like sort of lifestyle I have a house
that I did for HGTV i renovated a house
in Italy that was my
great-great-grandfather's house and I
bought it and renovated it and now I
live in this village of well part part
time obviously it's a village of 500
boitano's that it's a small village we
and
what yeah it's where every Boitano came
from in the world that's that's my last
name
Boitano yeah see what I'm saying about
the kids let it go let it go
you related oh yeah a five on every
single Boitano who is in the world came
from that one little village is that
hard to understand
that's crazy I've never heard of that
that's amazing - everyone's like a lot
of people still live there and well
other boitano's because they're
originally from there so my ancestors
immigrant blood either right they're not
all blood it's just the last thing or
are they all blood - well most boitano's
are all related most my toes are how
related who do you breed with other
people called poor da nose or all right
Kara jeana's Jared cherry geena's there
were four family names that were in
there so it's like they're not all oh
but I said every every Boitano came from
there so anyway I I went back and i
renovated that house
and so we okay Brian Boitano thank you
so much things that really
[Applause]
so that's a that's a first question
we've heard from this stage who do you
bring with it's like we got a safer I'm
writing that one down she makes sure all
of our speakers look it's it's a
tradition it started out as a joke but
we have to ask it it's wait till Damon
gets that one